[Music]
how's the gun man my name
look at Max's boy cry Oh fear a lot of
people suggested ID sir but I don't have
the scissor anymore and granted my
shrink I know why he wants to kind of
take my arm all right apparently there's
a door here to the left somewhere
someone said it at least that it is to
the left to the left everything you own
in a box to the left all right
I just hope no more of these little tree
[ __ ] shows up I don't trust you trees
I didn't get in all right no problem I
think we're actually good from the tree
[ __ ] oh oh that
no more Blair Witch Project girl said
that that last episode was whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa I would rather just
[ __ ] make love to Gideon
or going down there are you [ __ ] is
this SCP right here oh no senorita's
all right going down here this is Norma
this Dame does got a lot scarier since
the last episode holy sugar ochre I say
your hair ah there you have it you too
heavily hey vine Oh
Boogedy beat LA ha whoa
left right I'm skating like a boss whoa
whoa
stop
Ron made it
Ron oh nice blood everywhere as a thank
you I was thinking about that [ __ ] right
that steeps sounds like I'm peeing
alright go back about
go yes yes I'm not cheating thinking
about later I don't trust this one
come back at anything [ __ ] come back
America
no problem
come on another one they're difficult I
have to give I mean
yes
come on [ __ ] killer
go go what it shakes me Oh I'm supposed
to go here Wow
he slapped my [ __ ] up
whoa Holly sugar back up Oh
goodbye my god oh whoa whoa whoa
come on come on
mala mala
George oh no hey slap my [ __ ] up back
up back up
back up back up
Oh
shut up you [ __ ] non-game you're not
the monkey backup not too much a backup
yeah in the boss and the boss
you see kicking me no no no no [ __ ]
chainsaw guy down here rather kill
myself
Oh Kruger's alright oh thank heavens
lamp we're good
this game just keep getting worse and
worse when I think it's gonna
oh no it's it's fine it starts raining
well it's not fantastic that's all right
let's this rain don't mind being wet
that's what she said
alright is there anything here like
adrenaline or anything though alright
alright it's fine khadiyah stop trying
to kiss my arm down to pee hey Yannick
sorry what are you doing here
alright it reminds me oh it stinks huh
guy and gas mouse get whatever don't
judge me
alright he went in there let's see what
he wants you can wait did I come from
here you can do what you want the
opportunities down and it if I walk
backwards
you can be returned a
yeah you can make it all true and you
can make
dude singin in the brass you see I guess
it's locked and I need a key or
something oh it actually what well I'd
be fine dandy of my shiny they're not
sound good
oh it actually why all right twice and
actually way hey Julia yeah I have
actually
I'm just looking for like extra stuff I
guess what is this
Mullen buyers mental hospital
well I guess we're insane in this is
where I like it all began or something
so that's what I'm guessing
hey I miss you TRL friend all right
hello is anybody out there
I don't know what I feel about this
place I sit in there like the tray tray
let um game play or whatever a lot of
[ __ ] RCD everywhere why start no
woman here it's not even finished this
kitchen all right it's not a hand no
it's not well I guess this is normal and
they in the mental hospital you know why
is it empty
well one will never know
well I will never know probably I'm
think we should go upstairs or something
- for are you
there's sheep he goes down open the gate
blocking the stockades needs electricity
all right probably in the basement let's
check it out oh no bad things in the
basement always or maybe this is why
we're supposed to go okay we can go here
hello anybody out there
oh this is so creepy come on this
RAK being forbidden I've been thinking
oh I just get worse and worse I mean
this looks like I'm in Tracy room so
that's not bad again
what are you who are you and what are
you doing here this is a tough phone
alright it hey hey wow it's a tiger
living in there I saw that possible way
too easily I don't know if whoa what was
that I was my good for my at the brain
background everyone just comments about
it even if I say it's my girlfriend
everyone's like who was that in
background that's so creepy it was my
girlfriend okay just somebody freaky
talks about it
alright I'm not gonna follow these
information up locate the doctor I met
his outside or something oh oh can eat
you little [ __ ] and your baby too
ah don't shoot me don't shoot me I'm
innocent
that's what you get I have a gun now
come whoa no oh no he's she's locking
him in with their sexiness no I didn't
say
ah here out of all places I see in a
couple minutes Bros alright we're back I
kill you
and we got the Glock isn't that lovely
whoa no no no no not again not again not
again I think any other girl you know
they're always like hey what am I
supposed to do she's not in the same
room it makes no sense that she would
kill me wait oh no don't tell me I saved
their out of all [ __ ] places are you
kidding me no no no this is where I say
this is where I say wait maybe you shake
or something
shake it shake it like a Polaroid
picture it said something like shake the
river no it's not true it's not true I
believe in you
wait wait wait wait wait maybe if I
change weapon I can't change what that
what well maybe I should click I should
click I should click taking like a mouse
clicking like a boss yes yes yes baby
girl
there you go you think you're gonna play
basket whoa
I missed you I missed you come here you
sexy [ __ ]
we got work to be done Oh serene for me
fine and dandy drop their landing then
we take the drugs dollar kids don't look
it's not good for your there we go and
then pick up the lantern I guess what am
I am i running they have the gideon
africa all right here we go this is good
the fire doors are sealed shut
well y-yeah yeah you're coming with a
leak it's not coming it's a door here or
somewhere boy some hoops think you
should basketball our way I don't know
why it's called the basket oh yeah I
guess it makes sense Wow
I'm so smart sometimes it's really good
I guess we gotta find the fire thing
play to win but be respectful
that's a gays yeah I ever heard all
right I guess you you you little misty
you nearly [ __ ] my life
there you go there you go talk to the
floor all right we go here Oh bowling my
life do do do do do do do do do is
anyone out there
let's me bowling peace [ __ ] but is
this hospital have bowling and
basketball and a Glock magazine and a
note that says I love you there's
something strange about dr. Pernod I
thought it was a love you note free
shoes oh no this is just happiness
regular
never smell a bombing victims show
respect always a bathing structures [ __ ]
that visitors are not allowed to use the
facility if whatever patients I know
visit after five personal and visiting
patients in what what what all right
soaps someone dropped a shout in chat
all right that's all the time I had for
today brothers like and favorite if you
enjoyed subscribe to come abroad today
and I'll see you next episode alright
that's it good job boy you find in a row
during the rough college I don't know
what's at it stop kicking me can't you
for being a bad father